on our way to the most affected areas of
Noto Peninsula we're met by a road
closure now I'm driving on local roads
I'm not sure how long it will
take along the way we see several homes
abandoned and leveled and long lines at
petrol
stations sirens sound as ambulances from
across the main island of honu race to
rescue people in need
suddenly a warning to Halt there's a 5.5
magnitude Tremor nearby we finally
arrived at Noto some 30 km south of the
epicenter of that Quake where many
elderly people call home they tell us
they were simply shocked at the level of
Destruction with so many structures
needing to be
rebuilt It Feels Like
Hell K is one of the lucky ones ones
though his Barber Shop of five decades
sustains some structural damage and the
water is off it's still standing after a
massive earthquake and tsunami warning
on Monday had hiroa and his wife raced
to a shelter they're only just coming to
check on the shop he says they'll stay
and he hopes others will as
well we're cleaning up outside my tools
are not damaged when the water comes I
think I might work a little longer I'm 1
and a half years old now healthy and my
hands still
work tens of thousands of buildings were
reduced to Rubble in the magnitude 7.6
Tremor and it's feared many people are
still waiting for rescue some areas are
inaccessible due to demolished roads in
suzu with one of the highest casualty
counts supplies are so low that this
evacuee says he's only had one cup of
water in 3 days leaders have appealed
for help to get here faster elsewhere in
the city a man watches workers carry out
his wife's body from what has been their
home a loss that cannot be undone by the
line of ambulances and fire trucks
filing into the disaster zones Unis Kim
aljazera Noto
Japan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer